[Música]
existe uma questão muito importante que
é a agilidade na execução de todos os
projetos que envolvem o que a gente
chama de tríplice efe
é preciso quando a gente pensa em
governança ágil que todas as pessoas
estejam no mesmo ritmo estejam passando
ou vídeo dançando a mesma música pessoas
representantes das universidades governo
empresas precisam estar juntas na mesma
sintonia e ainda estarem ouvindo e
dançando a mesma música
elas precisam estar muito à vontade de
fazer de resolver de resolver rápido as
coisas e aí o conto pra vocês é possível
ter governança ágil na tríplice hélice
é possível que universidades governo
empresas ajam de forma rápida em
sintonia
a experiência de vocês quando vocês vão
fazer algum projeto envolvendo o governo
ea empresa ea universidade qualquer tipo
de projeto envolvendo os 3 acontece de
forma rápida e fluida ou é um processo
burocrático cheio de memorandos e
ofícios e colherá que as intermináveis a
gente poder chegar onde a gente quer
chegar
depende depende da situação depende da
instituição depende de quem depende
muito mais das pessoas depende das
pessoas estarem com vontade de estarem
no mesmo ritmo na mesma vaga
e aí eu tenho uma boa notícia para vocês
é possível sim fazer as coisas mais
rápido mitigar essa burocracia
apesar de trazer arquias apesar de tudo
que já está concretizado sacramentado
nessas instituições desses três setores
e se existe um grande vale um grande
abismo um grande vazio uma grande
distância entre universidade mercado de
governo
eu acredito
com toda a minha vivência que existe um
grande não saber conversar
a falta de comunicação porque sem
comunicação sem interação sem
colaboração não vamos chegar ao
resultado que queremos que é a rapidez
que resolver as coisas que a fazer as
coisas acontecerem porque porque eles
falam línguas diferentes
a universidade a empresa eo governo não
fala a mesma língua
não fala por isso é preciso que nós
estamos aqui hoje passamos a construção
todos os dias de pontes e pontes só
desde o bastante para fazer essa ligação
pra que o nosso caminho seja fluido sem
obstáculos pontes fortes o suficiente
pra aguentar toda essa diferença
[Música]
mas como fazer isso somente a quem achar
como fazer
dá para fazer um governo mais ágil e aí
governança ágil a partir desses cinco
pontos entendimento tradução conexão
hassan e acompanhamento é idéia eu quero
compartilhar hoje com vocês e vocês
implementem amanhã nas instituições onde
você está
as universidades às empresas eo governo
são bichos diferentes eles não se
relacionam da mesma maneira
eles não se alimentam das mesmas coisas
eles não interagem do mesmo jeito
eles têm objetivos diferentes mas a
premissa da governança' jyo é que haja
entendimento é que esses bichos
diferentes já uma maneira se entenda e
para que eles se entendam muitas vezes é
preciso que pessoas nessas instituições
assumam o papel de interruptores de
produtores gente que consiga conversar
na mesma língua que consiga entender a
diferença de um bicho para o outro e
esse comportamento diferente e consiga
minimizar essa distância e quem são os
tratores onde podemos encontrá los aqui
nos rápidos de conexão dos ambientes de
inovação nas incubadoras de empresas das
empresas juniores especialmente os
parques tecnológicos que hoje está
avançando no mundo todo são
articuladores e são tradutores muito
poderosos dessas diferenças é uma boa
ideia pra vocês melhorarem
essa questão da tradução aqui na nossa
cidade
é que vocês criem situações em que haja
conversa
então desde eventos que vocês vêem a
organizar como esses encontros que vocês
vêem a organizar desafios de inovação
envolvendo empresas insistiu e
diversidades e até mesmo a criação de
ambientes especializados para esse
ambiente especiais pra isso por exemplo
espaços de colotto de trabalho
colaborativo públicos gratuitos
espalhados pela cidade
esses encontros aconteçam mas também de
nada adianta chiar nesses espaços que as
incubadoras que hajam partes que ajam
humps que as nossas elevadores como foi
falado aqui
de nada adianta a gente tem espaços
colaborativos pela cidade
se essas pessoas que estão representadas
a da tríplice é se não estiverem
conectadas e ela para a conexão aqui vem
junto com a palavra amorosa ela precisa
ser uma conexão de amor de sintonia de
mesmo brilho no olho
eu me lembro muito recentemente uma
reunião estava com uma diretora de uma
instituição de ensino
ela votou comigo raquel gostaria ponto
de fazer um evento com os alunos do
curso de sistemas de informação
envolvendo o empresário deu na hora
atenta ouvindo carinhosamente ela me
dizia me lembrei de um presidente de uma
associação de empresas que estava aberto
e falou quando tiver uma oportunidade
para fazer alguma coisa com alguma
universidade eu quero
não pensei duas vezes
peguei o telefone sem de morangos em
ofício
liguei para o presidente da associação e
prontamente atendeu porque já estamos
conectados em 30 dias uma instituição
pública e uma instituição privada estava
organizando o primeiro hackathon naquele
segmento regaton caso alguns de vocês
não saibam
durante o final de semana inteiro alunos
projeto uma solução prática para aquele
empresário para vender mandou utilizar
no outro dia em 30 dias desse telefonema
tinha 80 alunos trabalhando em uma
solução para essa associação de empresas
que no outro dia pode ser utilizada por
centenas de empresários de edição
amorosa ouvir com atenção
quem demanda algo e ouvir com atenção
quem tem algo a oferecer
e por falar em conexão essas fotos
mostram algumas situações do nosso o que
a gente chama de ecossistema de inovação
nossa cidade de uberaba
essas atividades são importantes porque
elas criam o sucesso de comunidade na
cidade fazendo com que essas
instituições convivam ainda mais criando
e aumentando os laços entre elas fazendo
com que ela se conheçam mais umas às
outras e criando aquilo que a gente quer
conexão e aí partimos pra a sol
a capacidade de agir de cada pessoa
escolhida para representar suas
instruções para serem os produtores é
que vai dar a velocidade da governança e
governos e ágil
a pobre a ação em fazer parte do
dia-a-dia de cada pessoa que vai tratar
desses assuntos nessas instituições
um outro exemplo que fala muito sobre a
ação porque é uma frase que eu gosto
muito é as melhores idéias são aquelas
que se realizam né
então vamos partir para a ação um outro
exemplo foi quando uma grande empresa
queria instalar a nossa cidade e
prontamente
nós acionamos todas as universidades
todos os órgãos de governo com os pais
ela iria conviver nos sentámos todos a
mão à mesa e trabalhamos um fórum de
ação
todo mundo mão na massa
no mesmo dia na mesma hora não foram
necessárias 10 12 milhões 24 memorandos
na lan
nós resolvemos à mesa todos juntos
atendemos todos os requisitos dessa
empresa
hoje a empresa está em construção depois
da só a idéia é compartilhar com vocês
esse cinco pontos
o último ponto acompanhamento como nós
fazemos acompanhamento dos projetos que
nós é total nos com o espírito de
governança ágil muito simples
a gente simplesmente cria grupos de
trabalho para cada projeto
agora só criar os grupos de trabalho
funciona a experiência de vocês disse
que funciona
a gente criou além dos grupos de
trabalho
a figura do alienador alimentou é do
grupo de trabalho tem uma pessoa que
voluntariamente se colocou como eu quero
ser animador desse grupo e o papel de
ser animador
é justamente esse não deixar a peteca
cair e não deixar que o grupo perca o
ritmo levarem as novas ao grupo agendar
as reuniões monitorar a cobrar quem não
está colaborando como grupo e até
sugerir e pessoas novas ou saída de
algumas pessoas no grupo
coloquem a figura do animador nos grupos
de trabalho de vocês que envolvam essas
instituições faz toda a diferença
e aí um corte action aqui agora vai
mostrar prática
então a partir de amanhã pessoal que
vocês já podem fazer você já podem quem
estuda procurar seus professores e falar
professor eu gostaria de fazer um
projeto junto com uma empresa mundial
vamos juntar grupos vão fazer se você é
empresário
esse é um problema que você tem tido e
fala vou estar a ajuda na universidade
vou procurar a universidade à faculdade
para me ajudar
se você é governo abra as portas para
essas duas instituições e queria que
eles desenvolvam soluções junto com você
universidades e empresas criem soluções
que vão fazer a vida da sua cidade
aquilo está ao seu alcance
muito melhor ir pra gente ter governo
usar só tem um caminho a mão na massa
agir
o entendimento de quem é cada
instituição se conectar a jeito de novo
agir agir agir e acompanhar essa idéia
eu queria compartilhar com vocês hoje
obrigado
[Aplausos]
o